Sister
[Music]
I just wanted to eat something delicious.
But after all, when I'm done with work, Yuna. I wanted to
tell my sister, Yuna-san.
Actually, I also talked to Fina about the fan club. The bear is so
cute.
That's what I think.
Yuna-chan, Yuna-chan, I was in a bit of trouble. I
thought you would say so. It's
already Yuna-san who is calling out the fisherman,
so
these kids who left you a letter from Elerora in Auto.
If you're with me, I'd
be happy if you could come with Hina-chan, like the girl who underestimated Yuna-chan when I saw her for
the first time.
Sister, you're
very popular, and that's
all you need when I met you. If you're a little bear, that's
fine. Mythril equipment is a gamer's dream. All of them together.  I'm
home
Rina
[Music]